we all have times in our lives where we
feel
broken
the claims that angelina jolie made
against brad pitt are very disturbing
she was saying that he became drunk and
he was acting erratically
in the fbi report obtained by e.t angie
claimed brad poured beer on her punched
the ceiling of the plane four times and
grabbed her by her head shaking her she
also claims that when one of their kids
asked are you okay mommy pitt replied no
mommy's not okay she's ruining this
family she's crazy at this point one of
the children whose name was redacted
yelled it's not her it's you you
expletive
angie goes on to allege that brad ran
toward the child but angie held him back
that's when she claims she was injured
describing one injury as a rug burn type
wound on her right hand jolie presented
photos as well as journal entries from
their children so when you can document
what actually happened on this private
aircraft that is substantial but legal
expert jessie weber says there's another
side to this story just because angelina
jolie has made these accusations doesn't
mean this necessarily happened and also
we can't forget that the u.s attorney's
office felt that there was a reason why
they didn't pursue charges against brad
pitt and maybe that's because there
wasn't enough to prove what angelina
jolie said happened happened
angie is now suing the fbi for their
records surrounding the case i'm not
surprised that she did this the question
is will it go anywhere the investigation
ended brad pitt wasn't charged there
wasn't an understanding of why he was in
charge and she feels that the fbi hasn't
been transparent about it if nothing
happens from this if no more details are
given if it's not reopened in any way
unfortunately for angelina jolie people
might forget about this and they might
forget about this fast
a source close to brad questioned
angelina's intentions for the lawsuit
quote it's antithetical to the best
interest of the entire family this is
all for show there is nothing new here
again brad was cleared of any wrongdoing
but the alleged incident may have been a
turning point it was just weeks after
this that he made a major life change he
quit drinking in 2017 pitt told gq i was
boozing too much and i'm really happy
it's been half a year now and truthfully
i could drink a russian under the table
with his own vodka
in 2020 he thanked bradley cooper i got
sober because of this guy
and every day has been happier ever
since i love you and i thank you
[Music]